a lot of your favorite r b and dance
tunes have killer background vocals that
you might not have noticed on your first
listen just check out the harmonies in
the chorus of Ariana Grande's thank you
next
[Music]
in this episode we're going to dive into
the world of background vocals and I'm
even gonna break down how I write vocals
for my own music
I have been a musician pretty much my
whole life but I never intended to be a
professional musician and by that I mean
I never thought that I could even really
afford to have a music career and have
that be like the thing that I do for my
job
music was always a constant in my life
is interesting to me now
I wouldn't like have assumed that I
would become an R B singer uh and I
think a big part of that is going to
Oberlin which is where my music career
really started I was asked to perform in
an R B Showcase and I sang a couple
keilani songs I was like a huge Kaylani
fan and no scrubs which I still perform
at almost all my shows
and I think that experience really
opened my eyes because I was able to see
that I could be an artist and I could be
an artist in this field without having
the music experience that I was taught I
needed to have this next song is called
green tea ice cream one of my songs that
has backing vocals that I love is green
tea ice cream the sounds that I came up
with just like felt like they belonged
there and I didn't want another
instrument to play that part so I made
my voice the instrument to play the part
[Music]
vocal layering has been a musical
tradition of cultures around the globe
for thousands of years prehistoric
hunters in Africa and Asia are known to
have used polyphonic singing which is
where individual vocalists sing unique
phrases and notes together in ancient
Greece A Chorus was a group of singers
that would describe the action of a play
through song and during the Middle Ages
organum described one or more voices
company a main Melody chant today
backing vocals are an essential part of
popular music and are used to give
tracks energy and depth background
vocals in genres like R B often include
two or more layers of the same note in
unison in order to give the vocals a
fuller effect this is often referred to
as doubling you can hear this in the
verse of what you did where the second
half of each line is doubled and I know
I've been holding guard for so long so
long and in rap music viruses often use
doubled vocals to highlight keywords at
the end of each phrase
[Music]
focal layers in the chorus or hook often
include harmonies unlike Unison vocals
harmonies use two or more notes
simultaneously
call me when you need call me in the
morning r b artists will sometimes use
three-part harmonies to give the vocals
the fullness of a whole course
[Music]
sometimes I think something like a voice
is a lot softer than something like a
brass instrument or even a full quartet
if I think that's something beautiful
there's just something so vulnerable
about using your own voice and I also
think that it keeps the track very light
and ethereal while still adding depth to
it and making it feel full so here's an
example of a two-part Harmony
and then this is an example of a
three-part Harmony
there is one line in the background
vocal like the one that I just sang that
I want to stick out more than the rest
of the background vocal so I want to
make sure that that line stays
consistent so that I can lower the rest
of the background vocals if that's what
I need to do so that's just all part of
texture and balance
[Music]
that brings us to ad-libs short for ad
libidum which generally means with
freedom in Latin this is where the lead
singer improvises a Melody usually over
the chorus of the song for example and
He Wasn't Man Enough Tony Braxton is
improvising new lyrics on top of the
original Melody
the ad-libs are clearly the lead vocal
and not the background however these
days ad-libs also refer to the
improvised lines added to hip-hop tracks
after the main vocals are recorded
this is to complement the lead vocal and
even create a counter Melody the last
background vocal we have for this
section is an ad-lib which is my
favorite
foreign
ERS often add calm response to repeated
choruses in order to give the section
more variety and emotional energy
[Music]
so in this part of the song you can hear
one of the main uses of calling response
and the way that I used it in the song
is to finish the sentence so the
sentence means one thing when it's just
a lead vocals but then when it's the
background vocals it's kind of a
finished thought when I perform green
tea ice cream live I feel like it's so
apparent how important the background
vocals are because I don't always have
the chance to perform it with other
singers so that is one of my songs that
if I have the chance I always perform it
with background vocalists backing
vocalists are singers that provide
background harmonies or a counter Melody
to the lead singer before the invention
of tape recording in the 20th century it
was impossible for the lead singer to
perform their own harmonies or double
their vocals in a live performance
those little moments are the moments
that I come up with first you know like
the little oh
riffs come first and then those long
vocal background vocals and harmonies
that kind of tie the parts together come
second for me because those are more
instrumental and those kind of make me
consider where the direction of the song
more than just this moment I want this
moment to shine
[Music]
all the background vocals in this song
have an effect on them
um in the mixing process but right now
they're just raw so it's gonna sound a
little bit differently than it would
sound once the song is like fully
produced in the pop music realm there
are often teams of people working on
individual tracks or albums vocal
producers are in charge of coaching the
recording artist as well as arranging
editing processing and mixing each take
to Perfection many songwriters and
singers are capable of doing this job on
their own but talented industry favorite
cook Harrell has made a name for himself
by creating the background and leading
vocal Magic on hit songs featuring stars
like Rihanna Beyonce and Justin Bieber
something I love about background vocals
is that you get to say things that you
didn't necessarily get to stay in the
lead vocals whether that's just because
it doesn't fit as well with a song or it
doesn't rhyme maybe you know or it
doesn't fit the theme as well or it's
just like a little secret for the people
that are really listening well or maybe
what you were saying was a little bit
vulnerable and you don't want to put it
front and center so I love r b because I
love how r b vocals are like like normal
line like you wronged me and then the
background vocals are like I throw your
things in the backyard you know like
that that is the kind of
background vocals that I was growing up
on so like you know Beyonce did that
Kelly Rowland like they're like the
queens of that kind of shade and like
Jasmine Sullivan you know even the vocal
riffs like the way that you riff
I feel like you can tell someone off
with a Volvo rib
and I have thanks for watching but
before you go we want to hear from you
what's your favorite track with
beautiful background vocals record a
video of yourself responding to this
question and send it to us using the
link in the description and you might
just see yourself in our next episode